et avec nous pour ce club Benjamin Morel
bonjour Benjamin merci d'être là et
Pascal Tournier bonjour Pascal merci
d'être avec nous rédactrice en chef
adjointe de l'ebdomadaire la vie on va
évidemment parler avec vous de la crise
agricole les blocages se poursuivent et
Gabriel hatal promet de nouvelles
annonces dans les prochains jours
va-t-il réussir à éteindre la colère
vous nous le direz Audrey Gabriel Atal
hier il a réservé au sénateur ses
annonces sur la décentralisation oui et
il leur a parlé avec des mots qui leur
font plaisir il a aussi salué le travail
de certains sénateurs sur la
décentralisation notamment on verra tout
ça dans quelques instants d'abord de
l'actualité dans nos
régions et on parle beaucoup de l'Union
européenne ces derniers temps pointé du
doigt notamment dans la crise des
agriculteurs on va en parler dans
quelques instants mais l'Union
européenne ce sont aussi des apports
souvent méconnus et du concret Audrey et
pour nous le montrer vous vous êtes
rendu à Nice oui dans les Alpes
Maritimes et j'ai voulu vous montrer
dans notre quotidien dans la vie de tous
les jours où se situe l'Union européenne
c'est donc à Nice et ça commence sur la
promenade des anglais on vous
suit un paysage de carte postal est
peut-être l'un des endroits les plus
connus de Nice nous sommes ici sur la
célèbre Promenade des Anglais totalement
réaménagé ces dernières années après
l'attentat meurtrier du 14 juillet 2016
des poteaux et des câbles anti-intrusion
ont été installés ils doivent permettre
d'arrêter un véhicule lancé à vivealure
juste à côté la piste cyclable a pour
but de faciliter les mobilités douces de
projets financés en très grande partie
par l'Union européenne cette piste
cyclable a
été
créé subventionné dans le cadre du plan
de relance après la crise sanitaire et
cette piste a été financée a eu un coût
de d'un peu plus de 300000 € et a été
financé à hauteur de 70 % par des fonds
européens un exemple concret de l'action
de l'Union européenne dans notre
quotidien pour pourtant quand on demande
au N soit personne n'en a aucune idée je
savais pas du tout qui l'Union
européenne avait financé
laicyclable de Nice on a aucune idée
nous de ce ce qui est alimenté par
l'Union européenne on sa rien j'écoute
un petit peu les infos mais ça je sais
pas il faut dire qu'il faut avoir l'œil
pour trouver ces petits panneaux qui la
testent des panneaux présents aussi dans
cette crèche municipale de 50 à 80
places fraîchement sorti de terre
l'Union européenne a financé la moitié
des travaux avec un but aider
l'employabilité des habitants on est
dans le quartier prioritaire de la ville
qui s'appelle Nissand tout simplement et
donc cette infrastructure sert à ce que
les mamans et les papans qui puissent
bénéficier d'une place de crèche
puissent aller retourner au travail
après avoir eu un enfant en France ce
sont les régions qui redistribuent
l'argent de l'Europe à travers des
appels à projet qui doivent permettre de
développer les territoires le problème
c'est qu'ils sont souvent méconnus et
les dossiers très compliqué à monter on
va noter vos projets on veut des projets
particulièrement innovants ce jour-là la
région Sud a donc organisé une formation
pour aider les acteurs du territoire les
associations les métropoles les villes à
monter des projets qui pourraient
correspondre à un appel d'offre sur le
numérique qu'on soit une collectivité ou
un acteur économique on n pas forcément
le temps et on n pas forcément
l'information aussi pour pouvoir cibler
au mieux son besoin et cibler au mieux
l'appel à projet et certains projets
auraient pas lieu si on avait pas eu
l'urope pe à nos côtés et c'est
important de le rappeler et les sommes
pour financer ces projets sont loin
d'être négligeables pour la mandature
2021-2027 la région Sud a obtenu 10
milliards d'euros de crédit européens et
voilà pour votre reportage audrait du
côté Nice ben on le voit l'Union
européenne c'est aussi du concret hein
oui et ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'en fait les dossiers sont assez
compliqués à monter et que les petites
communes elles ont peut-être plus de mal
à à monter ses dossiers à demander ses
crédits et en bénéficier c'est la raison
pour laquelle certaines régions font des
formations et c'est quand même très très
important pour que ce soit pas
uniquement les grandes villes qui
bénéficient de ces fonds B on compte sur
vous on montrer d'autres exemples on
suivra bien sûr tout ça jusqu au 9 juin
date des élections européennes et c'est
justement vers l'Europe vers Bruxelles
que seront tourner tous les regards des
agriculteurs aujourd'hui leur colère qui
s'est invité qui s'invite aujourd'hui au
menu du Conseil européen hier c'est Marc
fen le ministre de l'Agriculture qui
était à Bruxelles on va l'écouter on
peut pas avoir une pâqu je dis très
simplement très tranquillement très
pacifiquement mais qui se soit à ce
point complexe et qui se soit à ce point
incompréhensible tant pour parfois nos
administrations que pour nos
agriculteurs donc on a besoin de
s'engager résolument dans la voie de la
simplification vous avez des
agriculteurs aujourd'hui qui touchent
des aides et qui ne savent pas flécher
le pourquoi ils touchent des
aides donc on a besoin d'interroger
cette question c'est voilà Marc fen
alors qui parle de la question de la PAC
qui est évidemment assez connue
peut-être en tout cas l'une des choses
les plus connu de la part de l'Union
européenne en matière d'agriculture qui
pose la question du fléchage des AES
mais plus largement aujourd'hui Pascal
c'est vers l'Europe vers Bruxelles qu'on
vont se tourner les regards des
agriculteurs parce que dans la crise des
agriculteurs qu'on est en train de voir
il y a quand même beaucoup de choses qui
se jouent du côté de Bruxelles oui alors
c'est c'est c'est un peu le paradoxe
parce que c'est à la fois Bruxelles qui
les finance parce que justement à
travers à travers la PAC et c'est en
même temps Bruxelles sur au sens large
qui le suscite cette colère notamment il
y a y a quand même un sujet qui est très
très important qui va être discuté à
priori aujourd'hui c'est la question du
libre échange et notamment à travers le
le les accords du mercosour est-ce
qu'ils vont être signés pas signés ça
c'est un gros point d'interrogation et
c'est vrai que c'est en train de monter
dans le débat aujourd'hui à travers
cette question agricole la question du
protectionnisme euh euh agricole donc il
y a aussi on le sait euh il y a une
autre question qui va être posée pour
plus tardivement mais sur la question de
l'Ukraine aussi sur les importations de
produits agricoles qui sont bah a priori
plus avantageux et donc du coup qui crée
une concurrence déloyale donc il a ça
c'est la question de du libre échange il
y a la question effectivement des normes
qui qui est souvent ramené sur le devant
et surtout effectivement aussi des des
des aides comment son sont-elles fléché
qui peut enénéficier et cetera il faut
savoir quand même aussi que ça va être
aussi l'un des premiers textes qui va
être renégocié à l'issue des élections
européenne donc il y a aussi un enjeu
justement de de ce type là après il y a
une question politique c'est
peut-être il y a il y a un enjeu on voit
bien aussi autour de l'Europe des
élections européennes moi je pense qu'il
faut faire attention de se dire que
l'Europe a la cible de tout t les tous
les mots il faut voilà il y a un jeu à
jouer sur cette question là don fautire
avec lequel il faut faire attention ouis
un mot Benjamin sur cette union
européenne qui aujourd'hui plus que
jamais va être au cœur du mouvement de
ces agriculteurs oui bien sûr parce que
Gabriel Attal a parlé l'autre jour
d'exception agricole française en
parallèle avec l'exception culturelle
mais en réalité le parallèle est très
compliqué à faire étant donné queil y a
guerre de politique plus européanisé ou
voir plus internationalisé via les
traités de libre échange que
l'agriculture et donc ce faisant les
réponses à ce stade-là ne peuvent être
qu'européennes et en effet il y a tout
un tas de défis l'adhésion de l'Ukraine
déstabiliserait totalement la pack
déstabiliserait également le marché
intérieur donc la question c'est
qu'est-ce que l'on fait prévaloir parce
que évidemment on peut se dire dé
stabilisations mais de l'autre côté il y
a également un message politique à
envoyer dans l'évolution de l'adhésion
même si est très très loin de la coupe
au lèvre de l'autre côté le mercosour
c'est un problème pour l'agriculture
mais c'est plutôt bon pour pour
l'industrie allemande et donc ce faisant
vous avez un jeu d'intérêt qui s'oppose
en la matière le Green Deal qui est
attaqué parce qu'en réalité c'est ça qui
en matière de sur transposition ce qui
n'existe pas vraiment en fait sur le
fond et bien pose problème le Green Deal
outre le fait que et bien il s'agit de
remplir des objectifs écologiques et
bien c'est un peu le ciment de la
coalition au Parlement européen autour
autour du recela V derleen ça n'existait
pas lors lors des élections de 2019 ça
arrive après investiture Dua vonder
leyon et ça permet de cimenter sa
coalition c'est l'élément essentiel de
son bilan aller renvoyer une commission
une présidente de la Commission
européenne qui veut rempiler en disant
que tout ce qu'elle a fait c'est
problématiqu c'est pas forcément évident
donc vous comprenez que aujourd'hui à
bruxel et bien revenir sur cette crise
n'est pas facile qui plus est la
commission l'a dit et elle a raison le
processus législatif européen si on veut
changer des choses ça prend du temps
parce que il vous faut le Parlement mais
il vous faut également et bien une
majorité au conseil donc on peut prendre
des mesures d'urgence sur les jaers et
cetera mais si on doit changer de
paradigme ce qui peut-être possible
parce qu'il y a pas mal de pays qui sont
en train de bouger aujourd'hui eu égard
aux crises agricoles qui ne sont pas que
françaises et bien ça prendra de toute
façon plusieurs mois voire plusieurs
années avec un budget de la PAC qui est
prévu dans un budget plurannuel vous
comprenez qu'il y a encore loin de la
coupe au lèvre problème du gouvernement
c'est qu'il doit mettre de l'eau sur
l'incendie tout de suite Pascal je vous
donne la parole mais peut-être un mot
Audra pour bien comprendre ce qui se
joue aujourd'hui à Bruxelles pour No
agriculteurs il y a notamment trois
points qui vont être discutés
aujourd'hui alors en fait il se passe
pas grand-chose au niveau agricole ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que ce Conseil
européen à l'origine il était fait pour
parler de l'Ukraine et notamment d'un
nouveau paquet d'aide financière pour
l'Ukraine on s'en souvient ça a été
bloqué par Victor Orban donc aujourd'hui
normalement on est censé parler
d'Ukraine sauf
que agricole s'invite dans les débats et
d'ailleurs Victor Orban qui avait bloqué
le paquet d'aide financière en décembre
dernier il en a profité hier il a zappé
une réunion avec les autres leaders
européens pour aller voir les
agriculteurs et pour dire vous voyez
regardez ce que l'Union européenne fait
de mal pour vous les agriculteurs donc
il en a profité alors que sur le papier
on est censé parler d'Ukraine il y a
quand même eu des choses qui ont été
annoncées en amont de ce sommet européen
par la présidente de la commission et
notamment des mesures qui avaient été
mis en place à cause de la guerre en
Ukraine on avait notamment une
dérogation sur les 4 % de jacher imposé
ça ça devait être levé ça va être
poursuivi il y a aussi euh des annonces
sur le poulet ukrainien en fait comme
les choses sont bloquées en mer Noire il
y a de nouveaux couloirs qui avaient été
créés et qui passaient par l'Union
européenne avec une levée des droits de
douane mais là les producteurs les
éleveurs crient à la concurrence déloyal
donc il devrait y avoir une clause
d'urgence sur les importation de poulet
ukrainien et puis euh sur la question du
Mercosur qui est en négociation
actuellement la France s'y oppose alors
sur le papier on pourrait contourner la
France puisque c'est un vote à la
majorité qualifiée mais on écoute quand
même la France qui est quand même une
grande puissance agricole et puis une
grande puissance européenne donc là pour
l'instant la Commission a dit que les
conditions n'étaient pas réunies pour
poursuivre cet accord il est donc stoppé
pas arrêté on va dire stopper
temporairement merci beaucoup pour ces
précisions are Pascal oui jeis juste
revenir sur le sur le Green Deal c'est
que je pense qu'il y a aussi un enjeu à
mon avis qui qui qui pourrait être bien
sûr évidemment intéressant c'est que le
Green Deal la façon dont il a été conçu
bien sûr c'est des un panel de de
mesures en faveur de l'écologie mais il
a oublié la dimension sociale et je
pense que c'est ça qui peut-être aussi
pe être en réflexion au au moment des
élections européennes c'est mettre en
avant une Europe plus sociale plus qui
qui prenne en compte effectivement ces
inégalités et don et dont les
agriculteurs en premier chef par exemple
sont voilà ne sont pas touchés enfin
j'is concernés par voilà par des mesures
plus sociales ouais alors il y a ce qui
se passe du côté de Bruxelles puis il y
a ce qui se passe sur le terrain
actuellement Benjamin les les blocages
qui se poursuivent sur le territoire on
a vu hier soir des interpellations du
côté de ringi ce matin les autorités qui
demandent qu'on voie agin ringi de faire
demi-tour et et regagner le sud est-ce
que il y a urgence pour le gouvernement
à éteindre l'incendie on a l'impression
que le gouvernement promet tous les
jours de nouvelles mesures à venir mais
qu'on ne les voit pas vraiment venir oui
le problème c'est que éteindre un
incendie quand vous avez plus d'eau dans
le camion de Pompi c'est un peu embêtant
or si vous voulez il y a un peu le
triptique de l'enfer ici c'est-à-dire
que vous avez un mouvement très
populaire 90 % selon différentes
enquêtes 80 % des Français qui
soutiennent également le mode d'action
donc les blocages donc quand vous
arrivez avec ça vous pouvez toujours
essayer d'inverser c'est l'opinion la
réalité c'est c'est que s'il y a des
blocages il est plus probable que les
Français disent non mais c'est de la
faute du gouvernement les revendications
sont légitimes si jamais ils cédent au
revendication et ben je pourrais manger
mon biftech et ringist ne serait pas
bloqué donc c'est compliqué pour le
gouvernement en même temps il faut
maintenir l'ordre public parce que sinon
vous ouvrez la porte à toutes les
fenêtres comme dirait l'autre de l'autre
côté et bien deuxième élément du
triptique de l'enfer vous avez un
partenaire de négociation qui n'est pas
un partenaire aujourd'hui tout à fait
fiable tout bêtement parce que les
syndicats sont in concurrence il y a les
éle bientôt dans les chambres agricoles
et par ailleurs et ben vous avez une
FNSEA qui est dépassée par sa base et
donc on est loin on a beaucoup parlé de
gilet jonisation et cetera on en est
très très loin la profession est
organisée et on n'est pas tout à fait
dans l'horizontalité des gilets jaunes
néanmoins on a des syndicats qui n'ont
pas la même marche de manœuvre pour
rentrer en négociation et cogérer la
politique agricole comme ils ont pu le
faire pendant des décennies donc à
partir de là vous vous retrouvez face à
un interlocuteur qui évidemment montte
d'un cran et ne tient pas forcément ces
troupes de l'autre côté on revient sur
la question européenne la réalité c'est
que les marges de manœuvre que vous avez
ce que vous pouvez donner ça reste
relativement limité parce que évidemment
il y a quelques petites choses qui
peuvent être fait au niveau national
mais le fond du dossier le malaise
agricole général et bien il est beaucoup
plus profond et il vient notamment bah
d'une réorientation des politiques
européennes et là vous n'avez pas les
leviers vous n'avez pas les manettes et
si vous les activez à Bruxelles il
faudra convaincre vos partenaires et ça
prendra du temps donc ce faisons ét
éteindre l'incendie aujourd'hui c'est
pas forcément tout à fait évident on a
quelques mesures qui sont données mais
l'idée c'est que une fois que et bien
l'incendie aura aura ce sera bien
diffusé peut-être s'éteindra-t-il de
lui-même ouais est-ce qu' joue gros
gabrielal dans les prochaines heures
Pascal c'est sûr en tout cas c'est sa
première crise hein et donc à peine pris
avoir pris ses fonctions il il doit il
doit il doit faire face d'autant que
c'est quand même un un milieu qui qui ne
connaît pas excessivement bien en plus
de cela on voit bien que l'opposition et
notamment le le rassemblement national
exploite totalement cette cette séquence
se met véritablement du côté des
agriculteurs se se positionne
complètement après avoir un moment
d'hésitation en tout cas là c'est très
clair se positionne complètement
antiécolo donc voilà il a aussi cette
cette cet élément- là dans le à jouer
pour pour pour Gabriel Atal allez
justement on va parler de Gabriel Atal
il était hier après-midi devant les
sénateurs pour sa déclaration de
politique générale il leur a réservé ses
annonces sur les territoires et audre il
a évoqué des sujets qui plaisent
beaucoup au sénateurs et en même temps
c'est un peu une figure imposée he quand
on fait un discours devant la Chambre
haute on ne peut pas faire de discours
justement sans parler de
décentralisation le Premier ministre qui
a surtout fixé un calendrier sur
plusieurs points demand demandés de
longues dates par le Sénat le premier
c'est la clarification des compétences
entre les différents échelons
administratifs écoutez les compétences
des uns et des autres sont dans un
véritable casse-tête elles s'enchevêtre
c'est inefficace dans notreaction publ
c'est dangereux démocratiquement car
beaucoup de nos concitoyens ne savent
plus vers qui se tourner ne savent plus
qui est responsable de quoi et sont
souvent perdu déçu et sans réponse c'est
le cocktail parfait pour nourrir la
défiance et la colère autant dire le
cocktail parfait pour faire le lit des
populistes la règle doit être simple
pour une compétence il faut un
responsable et un financement dédié et
pour cela Gabriel hatal a rappelé qu'une
mission sur les compétences des
collectivités était actuellement mené
par le député Renaissance exlr Eric vert
qui a d'ailleurs auditionné des
sénateurs à ce sujet il rendra son
rapport début mai et ensuite le Premier
ministre veut un texte de loi sur la
base des conclusions texte de loi avant
de la fin de l'année alors justement le
principal intéressé Eric W était sur ce
plateau vous avez bien bien travaillé il
y a quelques minutes je vous propose de
l'écouter c'était sur les moyens donnés
aux collectivités justement pour cette
décentralisation réfléchir autrement à
l'évolution des finances locales pour
qu'er de l'économie on peut réfléchir il
y a des partages d'impôts nationaux
aujourd'hui la TVA est un impôt qui est
largement partagé par par aux
collectivités la télva l'État en perçoit
grosso modo moins de 50 % aujourd'hui
est-ce que on l'a fait de manière
consciente et cohérente non une première
piste sur le financement qui devrait
plaire aux élus locaux pour en revenir
au discours du premier ministre il aussi
que les préfets et autorités sur les
opérateurs de leur département là encore
c'est une demande de la chambre des
territoires il y a eu d'ailleurs des
applaudissement dans l'hémicycle en
réponse à cette annonce et enfin Gabriel
Attal veut créer un statut de l'élu
local alourdir les peines prévues en cas
de violence contre ces élus là encore
celles et ceux qui regardent
régulièrement Public Sénat en ont déjà
entendu parler puisque le Sénat a voté
une proposition de loi en ce sens pas
plus tard qu'à l'automne dernier mais
les choses pourraient s'accélérer
puisque le Premier ministre a fixé une
échéance sur ce ce point avant la fin du
trimestre ran ouais et un mot euh c'est
bon le financement le financement il
manque il manque un petit truc ben c'est
bon on en a parlé un un mot Benjamin
parce que audre a
rappelé Gabriel a promis une loi
décentralisation d'ici la fin de l'année
Eric vert il nous disait ce sera pas des
ajustements comme la notre ADS ce sera
une vraie loi décentralisation ça fait
depuis 2017 que les élus locaux
l'attendent est-ce que on peut noter un
changement de ton de la part du
gouvernement et on peut attendre de
vrais actes on a toujours une annonce
d'une nouvelle loi de décentralisation
c'est toujours l'acte 3 d'ailleurs
depuis l'Acte 2 rafarin on a chaque fois
une forme de redit chacun veut porter
son acte 3 et en règle générale au bout
de quelques années après on dit chaque
fois que ce n'était pas tout à fait
l'acte 3 ça va être le prochain et par
ailleurs et ben les lois qui sont les
grandes révolutions souvent n'emportent
pas de grandes révolutions parce que là
il y a des annonces de simplification de
clarification pas vraiment de
décentralisation quelle politique on
décentralise et cetera alors Eric vert a
ouvert quelques éléments sur un po
poouir normatif des collectivités ça ça
peut être relativement intéressant de
desserrer les taux règlementaires sinon
la simplification en effet c'est bien
intellectuellement je su tout à fait
pour il faudrait des compétences claires
parce que ça permet d'évaluer un bilan
et un projet pour les collectivités
c'est important on assie avec la loi
notutre on voit bien que c'est très très
compliqué pour deux raisons d'abord
parce que ce que vous prenez à l'un vous
le donnez à l'autre et donc je vous
laisse imaginer le jeu de gladiateur que
ça va être quand on va réunir les
collectivités territoire uni c'est joli
sur le papier mais quand vous leur
demandez de faire des propositions en
terme de découpage des compétences ils
sont pas d'accord parce que et ben ce
que vous prenez le département vous le
donnez à la région et regoupe les trois
associations des commune départementct
exactement et ensuite on a vu que ça ne
fonctionnait pas non plus tout bêtement
parce que il y a une porosité dans vos
compétences c'est-à-dire que ok vous
donnez l'emploi mais vous le donnez à
qui parce qu'en réalité développement
économique mais en même temps action
sociale donc département région et
cetera tout ça est pour eux et donc le
fait que on ait des compétences claires
c'est loin loin d'être évident vu le
nombre d'échelons on simplifiera pas le
nombre d'échelons parce qu'ils sont tous
prévus dans la Constitution donc à
partir de là ça limite les finances
c'est bien beau de dire je donne une
partie d'un impôt national mais ce que
veulent les élus c'est d'avoir un levier
sur leur impôts et donc de pouvoir
notamment modifier le taux or
aujourd'hui les impôts locaux on les a
quasiment tous sacrifiés taxe
d'habitation TP et cetera tout ça a
disparu et donc vous pouvez donner une
part de TVA mais qui c'est qui fixe le
taux de la TVA et ben c'est l'état donc
au fond vous transférez des finances oui
ça vient de la fiscalité mais la belle
affaire la réalité c'est que vous pouvez
pas toucher à vos ressources et si vous
pouvez pas toucher à vos ressources
dotation ou taxes bah c'est kifkif ouais
les mots sont là mais dans concret ça va
être compliqué à mettre en œuvre
peut-être Pascal oui et puis en plus
l'autre question est de savoir est-ce
que aussi l'état ne veut pas faire des
économies quand même ça c'est pas
tellement été abordé mais il y a quand
même aussi on sait bien que l'État
cherche toujours de l'argent je pense
qu'Eric vert fait quand même partie de
parmi les propositions c'est pas lui qui
sera la manœuvre mais en tout cas parmi
ses propositions c'est quand même
quelqu'un qui est qui vient de de du
monde de la finance enfin en tout cas
des comptes publics donc on peut
imaginer qu'il est aussi là pour faire
un peu des économies donc ça c'est quand
même aussi une interrogation après je je
je suis d'accord avec Benjamin sur le
papier moi je trouve ça plutôt
intéressant et on voit bien aussi qu'il
y a il y a une il y a une dimension très
politique on on le sait euh beaucoup de
de de Français se sentent entre
guillemets abandonné en tout cas par les
par les services publics on parle de la
question de du des déserts médicaux de
la question de de la proximité
effectivement des des services publics
donc on voit bien que cette cette
proposition enfin ces propositions vont
essayer de de de palier à ce enfin de
répondre à ce à ce manque à ce besoin
donc là encore une fois comme par hasard
il va il va sortir ses conclusion au
mois de mai juste avant les élections
européennes donc il y a je pense qu'il y
a aussi une dimension politique qui
n'est pas à négliger ouais début mai
effectivement ce sera un mois avant les
les européennes est-ce que c'est aussi
un moyen Benjamin de de contrer le RN
qui fait aussi sont lit sur cette
absence des services publics et cette
France qui se sont délaissé alors vous
savez moi j'ai deux domaines de
spécialité en recherche c'est le
Parlement et les collectivités
territoriales j'aimerais vraiment que ça
intéresse au point que tout d'un coup un
rapport sur la décentralisation je sais
que au sénateurs je parlerai à leur cœur
mais changerait totalement les phases la
phase d'une élection la réalité c'est
que quand vous commencez à parler au
français des collectivités des niveaux
de compétences et cetera vous leur
parlez serbau croite et encore je suis
très très gentil donc je suis pas sûr
que là on crée un souffle si vous voulez
le mois de mai c'est très très loin le
monde politique sera très différent il
faut voir qu'aujourd'hui regardez la loi
immigration elle triple de volume il y a
aucune loi qui ne qui n'est autant
modifiée dans un parlement qu'une loi
sur les collectivités territorial tout
bêtement parce que les élus ne nstant
leur parti ajoutent des trucs et cetera
aujourd'hui quand vous discutez un petit
peu avec les associations de
collectivité en H évidemment il faut il
faut une nouvelle loi de
décentralisation ENF on vous dit ouh là
là et on sait pas exactement comment
sortira le frankinstein de l'état actuel
de l'Assemblée nationale c'est-à-dire
que actuellement vous lancez quelque
chose dans le processus parlementaire en
la matière est que ça prod produirit en
terme normatif les conséquences sur les
collectivités avec des députés
quiikiplusé sont pas les plus ancrés
qu'on a connu sous la 5e République
risque d'être extrêmement bizarre
problématique et pas forcément assumable
par le gouvernement donc il faut je
crois être extrêmement prudent mais
c'est très loin la fin de l'année c'est
un autre monde ouais mais est-ce que
justement l'enjeu c'est que alors
effectivement la question de qui fait
quoi et quel niveau quel échelon à la
compétence de ça ou ça ça passionne
effectivement peut-être pas les Français
mais est-ce que l'enjeu pour de ce
rapport et pour gouvernement c'est que
ça se traduise concrètement pour les
Français quis a des services publics à
proximité de chez eux et que du coup ils
mettent fin peut-être à ce sentiment de
délaissement on a vu pendant les gilets
jaunes on le voit aussi peut-être un peu
avec ce mouvement des agriculteurs il y
a un enjeu évidemment mais cet en jeu il
est complexe si vous voulez pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que aujourd'hui
encore une fois le procè normatif n'est
pas tout à fait cadré pour faire ça
ensuite ça implique de l'argent il y en
a pas he il faut être tout à fait clair
une politique publique ça implique de
l'argent or on va pas en transférer plus
aux collectivités parce qu'il y en a
plus de l'autre côté faut un pouvoir
normatif et ça ça implique pas de
grandes révolutions ça implique que les
ministères retiennent leur plumes quand
ils écrivent les projets de loi et les
décrets d'application on n'est pas
capable de le leur obliger donc il
faudrait peut-être une réforme
constitionnelle en la matière il y a pas
la majorité pour la voter ensuite il y a
la question des compétences la
lisibilité des compétence mais je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure bah c'est souvent un
peu une vue de l'esprit et on n arrive
pas donc là encore prudence ouais est-ce
que l'enjeu aussi c'est peut-être que
quand les Français vont voir leur maire
pour leur parler de tel ou tel problème
le maire ne réponde pas ben je peux pas
le faire parce que je suis bloqué par
tel ou telle norme ou parce que je suis
bloqué par l'État c'est aussi ça l'enjeu
de cette loi oui oui c'est en fait en
tout cas on sent bien que ça ça ça ça
poursuit la la tonalité qui avait été
donnée par le Président de la République
lors de sa conférence de presse c'est
côté bon sens près de chez vous on voit
bien il a été très dans la très précis
dans dans les dans les annonces dans les
dans les propositions Gabriel hatal dans
son discours de politique générale ça a
été aussi critiqué hein d'ailleurs par
par ses détracteurs mais il y avait
cette cette cette un peu cette
impression de boîte à outil il y a plein
de petites mesures très voilà c'est le
bon sens près de chez vous donc je pense
que ça répond à cette
même même besoin enfin en tout cas envie
du gouvernement d'être de de de de
donner le sentiment que c'est que que
les pouvoirs publics sont efficaces dans
le quotidien des Français vraiment au
plus près du quotidien des Français mais
je reste tout à fait d'accord avec
Benjamin c'est peut-être très bien sur
le papier et je sera plutôt bien
évidemment louable mais reste à voir la
faisabilité et c'est là où aussi le
danger justement c'est de de de les les
Français aujourd'hui dans le crédit
vis-à-vis des politiques c'est C des
paroles des paroles des paroles mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe véritablement
dans les actes et ça c'est la toute la
difficulté aujourd'hui pour le
gouvernement qui lui-même aussi a joué
ce jeu-là donc je demande à voir oua et
et comment faire aussi peut-être pour
que les actes impriment parce que dans
sa conférence de presse Emmanuel Macron
par exemple il a parlé des maisons Fran
servic il a dit qu'il y en avait plus de
2000 qui avaient été mis en place pour
que chaque Français et les services
publques à au moins ouais proximité
c'està-dire pas plus de 20 minutes de
chez eux mais est-ce que les Français
le voit et est-ce que les actes qui sont
faits par le gouvernement ils sont
forcément perçus par les Français est-ce
que c'est pas là aussi la difficulté du
gouvernement mais ça c'est c'est j'ai
envie de dire c'est la c'est ça aussi
propre de la politique c'est le
savoir-faire et le faire savoir hein
donc il faut faut sans cesse marteler
marteler j'aiaiindiiqué moii vous parlez
des maisons France serv bon j'ai eu je
vous parler d'un mon cas personnel j'ai
été effectivement amené voilà on m'a dit
bah voilà pour telle ou telle action
vous devriez aller voir la maison France
service donc je je vais y aller bien
donc je vous dirais l'efficacité de ces
maisons France service je ne savais pas
qu' effectivement qu'il en existait à
Paris donc donc voilà oui vous avez
raison ça met du temps je pense que ça
met du temps il faut effectivement
encore une fois le le le faire sair il
va y avoir un double enjeu dans cette
loi bengermain à la fois évidemment le
côté technique le côté pratique de
répondre aux élus mais aussi un but
politique et un but de communication
l'écard des Français sûr bien sûr il y a
un but de communication mais là encore
une fois c'est-à-dire que prenez la loi
3DS ça devait être à la fois une
révolution et une simplification
personne n'a compris cette loi et donc
aujourd'hui quand vous avez qui fait 40
propositions tout m dit ou là là mais
c'est horrible comment peut-on faire ça
bah oui mais vous l'avez voté et donc la
réalité c'est que il y a je dirais une
forme là-dessus de boîte de Pandor quand
vous ouvrez vous tout d'un coup vous
construisez des textes qui sont des
usines à gaz et qui sont pas du tout
vendlables à l'opinion et ce qui a été
dit est très important quand vous prenez
les études en sciences politique sur
justement le le faire savoir en réalité
il faut de la stabilité c'est-à-dire que
si jamais prenez par exemple PUL emploi
Paul emploi euh France travaille et et
avant la NP pour vous et moi qui suivons
à peu près le dossier on comprend
l'affiliation mais pour le français je
dirais qui n'est pas passionné de
politique mais qu'est-ce qu'on a fait de
la NPE c'est quoi et France travaille
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est-à-dire que
pour tenter de montrer qu'on change le
réel on change les cyles on change les
institutions on change les lieux
également vous avez des études sur les
tribunaux américains qui montrent
notamment que les tribunaux avec les
colonnes cor mtienne c'est identifieré
en revanche les grands immeubles en
banlieue parisienne ça ça allit pas et
donc vous avez besoin de permanence pour
montrer que et bien il y a une politique
et il y a une continuité mais pour
montrer que vous changez et ben il faut
toujours tout renouveler et donc à force
de vouloir tout renouveler on donne le
sentiment qu'il y a peu d'autorité
publique et pas d'autorité publique
égale pas d'action publique allez on
suivra tout ça évidemment on va reparler
du mouvement des agriculteurs c'est à de
vos quotidiens
régionaux
et audre le mouvement des agriculteurs
se poursuit et fait toujours la une de
nos quotidiens oui avec cette image
forte qu'on a pu voir hier et qu'on
retrouve en Une de La voie du Nord des
blindés face au tracteurs pour les
empêcher de bloquer le marché de ringis
en Île-de-France le plus gros marché de
gros justement du monde les agriculteurs
qui maintiennent la pression aux portes
de Paris et sur les autoroutes en
province en Meur et Mosel la 31 et la 33
sont toujours coupé ce jeudi la
situation devient de plus en plus
compliquée sur les routes route
secondaire alors Nord éclair s'interroge
qui gagnera le bras de fer entre les
agriculteurs et le gouvernement c'est la
question mais en page intérieure on peut
lire un témoignage de cultivateur qui
dit on attend bien plus que les
mesurettes du gouvernement dans ce
contexte c'est dans ce contexte que le
Courrier de l'Ouest est allé recueillir
et c'est super intéressant le sentiment
des étudiants en agriculture une
profession qu'ils ont embrassé avec
vocation soit pour être salarié soit
pour reprendre l'exploitation de leurs
parents ils disent soutenir le mouvement
espère que cela restera pas pacifique et
eux aussi s'inquiètent des normes
européennes qu'ils estiment impactantes
pour l'élevage et de la concurrence
déloyale selon eux des accords de libre
échange mais pas question de renoncer à
leur projet la crise ne freine en rien
leur motivation orienne et l'actualité
aujourd'hui c'est aussi la grève dans
l'éducation nationale oui vous l'avez
peut-être remarqué de nombreux
enseignants et responsables
d'établissements sont en grève à l'appel
des principaux principaux syndicats
parisnmandie nous en explique les
raisons elles sont nombreuses manque de
moyens face au changement réforme des
lycées professionnels revalorisation
salarial ce sera donc un jeudi noir dans
l'éducation annonce le Télégramme les
enseignants qui seront aussi dans la rue
cet après-midi une manifestation est
prévu et puis Orian aujourd'hui on
faitte si on peut parler de fête les 70
ans de l'appel de l'abé pierre c'était
le 1er février 54 et son appel raisonne
encore d'après l'Union et charante libre
il avait alerté à l'époque sur la
situation des S logis le logement qui
reste un sujet encore aujourd'hui dans
notre pays la Provence en parle ce matin
parle d'ailleurs d'une bombe sociale et
on termine on va chez vous pour terminer
par une note positive oui la tech fait
son festival à Grenoble c'est en une du
Dauphiné Libéré 10000 participants sont
attendus aujourd'hui et demain pour
découvrir le meilleur de l'innovation et
de la technologie et il y a un projet
qui a retenu l'attention du Dauphiné
Libéré c'est celui de la start-up
Spartan Spartan space j'espère qu'on va
le voir un habitat lunaire gonflable un
refuge déplaçable autonome qui permettra
de soutenir les mission d'exploration
lunaire orien oui ça rigole pas merci
merci beaucoup Audrey on parlait de
cette grve des profs les le scolaire
c'est à la Une de La Vie Pascal public
privé les nouveaux fronds de la guerre
scolaire oui c'est faire un peu l'état
des lieux et surtout chasser un peu les
idées reçues concernant l'enseignement
privé voilà c'est un dossier qu'on a
fait grâce
à c'est cette semaine dans la vie merci
Pascal tour merci Benjam d'avoir été
avec nous merci Audrey merci à tous de
nous avoir suivi on se retrouve demain
et à 18h vous avez rendez-vous avec pour
s public très bonne
journée